I'm a host and presenter for undercover  afrobeats events but nobody knows I did  my masters nobody knows I do undergrad  nobody knows I'm a stem student and I'm  a BSC and I'm Australia geek no one  knows that no one cares for that no one  asks that was a fun fact why didn't you  say it  because it's boring because it's boring  who is it boring for yeah  maybe that's the same thing Lisa was  saying exactly modern people think it's  boring I find that I find it really  fascinating and that for me that's  something you should lead with that's  true because there's a special more  special that is something be careful  makes you on the track everybody that is  something no no everybody  exactly but at the same time as a black  woman and you're now what you're  educated double educated you're you know  this or that you want to be more you  here man away guys I want to get married  no no but that's what Society no that's  what society makes